foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
six bets we love NBA we are here we are
live
my name is Greg as you guys know uh we
got live moods producer Ryan
but before we get started before we get
started Ryan give him that odds boost
that we've been talking about we got a
special odds boost pull it up for us
Ryan
all right so here we go we've got Kevin
Durant to score 30 points tonight for
the Brooklyn Nets against the Sacramento
Kings and the Nets to win boosted from
plus 185 to plus 270. Now Greg you know
how I feel about the Nets I don't like
them very much uh they're not on my good
side but how can you not take the size
boost at Plus 270. a back to back think
yeah the Kings play yesterday
you play The Warriors
no no no they did not they did not play
yesterday I'm sorry but if whether it's
a back to back whether it's not a
back-to-back I love the Nets and Kevin
Durant against the Kings and him to
score 30 points I'm riding Liv how about
you
I like it a lot I think especially
without Kyrie Irving you can expect
Kevin Durant to to be uh floating around
a little 30 piece anytime Kyrie's not
out there so I like it
there it is let's get right to the show
let's get right to the show because
everybody is here for a specific reason
once again my name is Greg Ivory I'll
introduce
the sharp we call live moods in the
middle uh she has all her bet she's
gonna give us those six Best Bets and
then you guys know him producer Ryan he
is the bridge to you guys he's the
bridge to us to you guys uh he is a man
of the chat uh live
we're ready we're ready for your six
Best Bets I need everybody to drop your
Best Bets in the chat me and Liv we will
talk about them later in the show but
live let's get right to it 45 seconds
it's on the clock and we get 45 seconds
please live
when it's over with this first bet
please
I'm actually looking at a little bit of
a Futures bet here this is one that I
took before the season started it's kind
of a hot take especially as a nuggets
fan but I like the Clippers to
potentially win it all this year the
value is too good to resist so I did
sprinkle on it look I mean they made it
to the playing games last season with
Kauai having played zero games and Paul
George only playing 31. I love the depth
of this team I think that they've got a
real shot this year if they can stay
healthy obviously we can't really
handicap for health and that's kind of
out of our control but I love this star
duo in Kauai and Paul George I think if
they can stay healthy with the depth
that they've got and the play-making
ability that they've got I really think
that they could do something this season
so I'm gonna go Clippers to win it all
you threw a curveball like I just want
to let you know I want everybody to know
that's watching the show live is the
first probably since like our future
show which was like specifically for
futures but Liv is the first to come on
the show
on a regular Tuesday during the NBA and
drop a future quick there it is the Los
Angeles Clippers who win the
championship
you know I don't know how I feel about
that but that is okay though talk to the
chat let's talk to the people let's
bring in producer right producer Ryan
come on back in here talk to us talk to
the people are they feeling Liv's pick
or are they in the comments talking
about something else
the chat's trying to fire me up right
now I've been chirping the chat for a
little bit but uh all right we got
Michael bowling in here saying live for
sure the sharpest we got now I don't
know if that's uh I don't know if that
shots fired at Sam Richmond or if that's
just a compliment but uh bagel and lox
jumped in here and said producer Ryan
Sixers to win it all I like the Clippers
uh far more than the Sixers
um we've got
mhb4 Now Greg we always talk about
scoops on this show he came in here that
that's all that's all we want said Zion
is four and one versus Memphis so
absolutely nothing to do with what Liv
just talked about but but Scoops
nonetheless which is very important that
isn't stupid Scoops are very important
here Liv uh Ryan let's send you back
let's send you back to the chat go go go
keep them warm and Liv's actually going
to keep them engaged because she's
coming with her second pick of six let's
put 45 seconds back on the clock please
there's the 45 second live are you ready
I'm ready
let's get right to it
I'm gonna keep it short and sweet with
this one I don't really need 45 seconds
for this one but I did do another's
Futures bet before the season started
and that's Giannis as the MVP listen
this is a nuggets fan saying this jokic
back to back I could root for yogic
again I love him but Giannis plain and
simple he is the best player in this
league and not situationally but
consistently it's not when a player goes
out or you know in a dire situation in
the playoffs and he's he turns it up in
the playoffs this is a consistently
great player best in the league by a
mile give me Giannis for MVP she left 10
seconds on the clock 10 seconds hold on
hold on let's say have you not been seen
with 30s been doing in Golden State
yes Greg of course okay I'm just making
sure I'm just making sure we're
acknowledging greatness here of course
dirty has been putting on the show in
Golden State also indeed indeed's been
putting on he just went for like a 50
plus the other day uh but yeah like that
love your futures picks list Futures
picks are there if you guys do not have
those tickets she's basically saying go
put those in right now all right Liv you
gave us two we got four more to go
we need 45 seconds on the clock please
so Liv can talk to us there's the 45
seconds live let's get right to this
next one
all right I'm gonna go sabonis tonight
over 12 and a half rebounds this has
been one of my favorite rebound props to
grab this guy is constantly hustling to
get boards throughout the game and
tonight he's facing the Brooklyn Nets
that are giving up the seventh most
rebounds to opposing centers in the last
seven games at an average of 17.17 per
game uh he's coming off of 22 boards
versus Golden State so I like him in
this spot to use some of that momentum
from last game into this game against
the Nets team that has really given up a
lot of boards to centers right now so
give me some bonus over 12 and a half
rebounds hey he went live there it is
I'm sorry I have to mention that the
time is on the clock this is a record
like seriously live everybody
comes on this show and they always talk
for more than 45 seconds I'm trying to
be timely trying to be timely short
sweet concise straight to the point I
love it I absolutely love it but I do
want to talk about someone he went
absolutely bunkers against the Warriors
and get grabbing rebounds the other day
uh so love this one feel like he's in
the groove uh Mike Brown got them out
there playing well in Sacramento well
for Sacramento that's you know they're
doing good for them but uh let's move on
Liv we got three three down three more
to go can we please get 45 seconds back
on the clock Liv might not use that 45
seconds but we need the 45 seconds there
just in case she gets a little talky but
go ahead live uh talk to him pick four
of six
I like Dylan Brooks tonight over 17 and
a half points we don't have Desmond Bain
as you know Desmond Bain has been one of
the leading scorers for this Grizzlies
team he's going off I think he's out the
next two to three weeks here so I like
Dylan Brooks to kind of pick up where
Desmond Bane left off
um he's averaging
19.4 points in eight games without
Desmond this season we know John Moran
is supposed to make a return as well but
I think he'll be a little bit more of a
facilitator you've also got Jaron
Jackson Jr making a return whenever
you've got star players that are making
a return I like to give them a little
bit of uh room to to mess up a little I
don't expect them to be perfect right
off the bat so I like Dylan Brooks to be
a leading scorer tonight I'm going to
take over 17 and a half points for him
without Desmond Bain
live up there it is the timer just went
off 45 seconds this time but she's
rocking with Brooks he's rocking with
Dylan Brooks to go over 17 and a half
points left he's ever since the Oregon
days I always liked him I liked his game
I like the way he plays and he's became
a Defender he's actually became a
Defender there's a lot of chit chat in
the playoffs around him
um
let's go to the chat producer Ryan come
on back come on back in here and talk to
us you are
the way we talk to the people so talk to
us what are they talking about producer
Ryan uh D sneaks jumped back in and said
he loves the Clippers to go all the way
so you got some you got some support
there
um around the MVP talk 6-4 says I like
embiid or Luca for MVP and we've got a
lot of we've got a Luca MVP uh stands in
here mhb4 says nobody's gonna mention
Luca so do you guys you guys have a take
on Luca for MVP at all
he's great
yeah that's right yeah it's not it's not
a bad bet you I mean it's Luca dances
yeah so he's gonna be around he's going
to be around top five at the end of the
year so it's honestly not a bad bet
you're just
playing with uh injury concerns and
playing the odds really so sprinkle it
yes sir uh Michael Boling jumped back in
here and said Ben Reed Ben Simmons is
the reason for the sabonis rebounds
um and then Silvio likes the over 229 in
Memphis New Orleans and likes the
Grizzlies plus three and a half
that one's intriguing the over we know
those offense like to go up and down the
court we know that they like to get up
and down and he said in Memphis plus
three
you see that thing that says Greg picks
at the top of your guy's screen stay
stay tuned you don't want to miss it but
the focus is on live the focus is on
live produce a run can we wanna send you
back to the chat and we're back on live
because she gave us four she gave us
four
all eyes are back on you live we need
two more
can we get 45 seconds back on the clock
please
live take it away
all right so uh producer Ryan mentioned
an over that people were talking about
in the chat one of my favorite bets to
look at right now is looking at a team
that plays at a really fast pace but
doesn't play great defense because what
does that mean they get a lot of points
scored against them so I'm looking at
this spot for the jazz tonight I like
their team total over 118 and a half
they're averaging 116.8 in the last five
games and they're facing the Knicks who
play at a top 10 Pace while also ranking
23rd in defensive rating so lots of
points against them tonight I really
like the Jazz take advantage of a fast
pace but a lack of Defense so give me
the over I like the Jazz to uh be
scoring a lot tonight and hit that over
118 and a half for their team total
there it is she left five seconds on the
clock but that was live that was a scoop
it's definitely a scoop she's betting
against that New York Knicks defense we
love that we love the strategy we love
the analytics and we love Scoops here so
if you guys don't know I know she just
gave us the Jazz team total over 118 and
a half
take it take a gander at it take a peek
at it maybe bet it who knows but she
gave us a scoop Liv that's five
we got one more
45 seconds on the clock please live take
it away
all right yeah so I'm gonna go with
Marcus Morris over 13 and a half points
tonight no Kawhi Leonard uh he's hit
this in three of the last five this is
one of those guys you get a little
nervous to bet on him because he can't
have the the highs and the lows Ebbs and
flows uh not the most consistent player
but as of late uh he's definitely
playing pretty consistently on offense
no Kawhi Leonard like I said so I expect
some of these other guys on offense
maybe a little bit for Reggie Jackson
obviously Paul George but I like a guy
like Marcus Morris when his line is
sitting at 13 and a half that's a number
that I definitely feel comfortable with
especially how he's been averaging in
the last five so because the number's 13
and a half I'm gonna take it if it were
any higher I'd be nervous but I'm gonna
go with his over tonight
there it is Liv she's rocking with
Marcus Morris over 13 and a half that's
not too many
too many or I couldn't have a day so go
out there and get some buckets up make
couple shots you'll you'll hit that one
all right uh let's bring producer Ryan
back on into here because we gotta tap
in with the people we gotta tap in with
the people producer Ryan
anything interesting going on in the
chat we have some interesting takes uh
Marlo Underwood says uh take the first
half over in the Jazz next game
no scoops associated with it it just
seems like Vibes uh six four says he
likes Jazz money line tonight
it is minus 200 so maybe take the points
um tie two goated
or you always say this but what it but
what am I parlaying it with Greg
I mean Liv just gave us six different
bets that's true that's a good point
it's a good point there we go
there we go six different Betsy but at
the top of the show like well okay okay
yeah that's true that's a good point
take your pick Ryan you've got six to
choose from
um and then we got Tai two goated in
here saying bucks or 76ers winning the
finals I since we started this show
we've had nothing but Sixers winning the
finals takes in this chat and I for the
life of me can't understand it I don't I
don't know why I don't I don't think
Philly's on a high I think Philadelphia
is on a high right now they feel
Untouchable you know I don't know how
the Eagles just lost I know yeah I know
Philadelphia Phillies lost too what's
the high I don't know but you know how
Philly fans can be they can be slightly
delusional that's a nicer word that I
would have used and the Philadelphia
delusion also lost the MLS by the way
there's a city there you go delusional
yeah oh my dog's barking like you know
what that means BET The Underdogs
because the dogs are
at the underdog wait what was the 100 uh
the Memphis Memphis that one might be
the lock of the day the dogs are barking
should we move on Ryan or are you done
brother I didn't mean to cut you up you
have any more interesting takes I mean
there's a lot of Jason Jason Tatum MVP
talking that's a Celtics fan we can just
do a 30-minute show on Jason Tatum um
but for the sake of the show we'll move
on to your pick Greg uh let's move on to
my favorite part of the show make sure
you guys keep dropping your locks I love
love six Best Bets absolutely actually
my favorite part of the show because Liv
she mixed it up she threw curveball she
threw Futures she threw tonight locks
she threw prop locks team totals she
mixed it all up but this time
it's my turn it's my turn and I was
looking at some player combos earlier
Ryan Ryan actually pull up FanDuel
please pull up FanDuel please uh all
right listen here guys
I'm not an expert I'm not a professional
I need your help
I'm asking for your help I looked up a
bet me and Ryan looked up this uh John
Morant to score 35 points and The
Grizzlies to win at plus 6 30. my
question is is this worth a Sprinkle my
man John Morant he averages 28 points
per game this year
he's coming back from not playing last
game a little bit of fresh legs will be
in the factor can he go get 35 Plus and
The Grizzlies to win
I'm asking you you guys help me Ryan
what are they talking about in the
comments actually before we get to the
comments Ryan
I'm asking I'm asking Liv you can jump
in here too is this something worth
sprinkling on
for sure absolutely I think the only
reservation I have in this spot for the
Grizzlies team is obviously they've got
injuries they've got some guys that have
been injured that are coming back but
this is a Grizzlies team that kind of
thrives off of being underestimated if
you haven't noticed they've got a lot of
grit they're very competitive John Moran
I mean who is he feeding the ball to
tonight besides Dylan Brooks obviously I
like Dylan to go over on his point total
so I think he will but other than that I
don't think he'll be feeding it to JJJ
he may need a game or two to kind of get
get into the swing of things no Desmond
Bane here so yeah I like it I think at
plus 6 30 definitely worth a Sprinkle
it's worth a Sprinkle that's all I'm
talking that's all I want to know if if
this is worth putting a little bit money
on just thinking about just thinking
about it my man John can go out there
get some extra buckets leading his team
to a win you're walking away with plus 6
30 odds Ryan I haven't heard from you
and you know a big Vibe guy you gotta
check your pods here
big big Vibe though Big Bob guy gotta
check your Vibes here and also gotta
check the Vibes of the chat how we
feeling well my vibes are great Greg I'm
I'm with you on this one I love it and I
love the value uh Jay Hernandez just
repeating what Liv said no Bane tonight
why not uh AJ the Don says no Desmond
Bane I see the points but Pelicans
taking the dub that's what we call bad
vibes
um bad vibes bad vibes uh Von Bizzle
same thing I like the 35 but the W I
don't know six four I think he can get
35 I don't know if they win if the pells
uh starting five plays Fair Zion is
questionable not sure if he's playing
um Fox 59 says nah I'm gonna say 25
points instead and then Gene Sanchez
under 29 and a half which is his line
total for tonight there's not a lot of
positivity in the chat Greg The Vibes
are kind of bad low-key honestly a lot
of bad vibes but live fear not fear not
because things don't change just like
last year we turned bad Vibes into good
advice and actually the squad at BR
betting yes we put together a same game
parlay for tonight Ryan Show the people
what's up
yep just like every week we make it nice
and easy on FanDuel and we have the nice
little same game parlay Banner on top
and then what you do is you see it right
here and then you go and you hit bet now
and boom what do we have tonight easy
easy money so easy Grizzlies money line
so we're aligned with you there Greg
John Moran
a plus assists John Moran 25 plus points
big big John Morant team here uh and
then Dylan Brooks Two Plus made threes
you parlay those four and it's plus 497
and like Liv said it's easy money
easy honestly I just want you guys to
understand like you can really get rich
today riding with us look at this parlay
that looks really good it's plus almost
plus 500 plus 497 it looks really good
but this parlay lines up to what I just
asked you guys was a good play like you
know what I'm saying do you see the dots
connected I I think they're connected
but uh Ryan
I'm ready to grade some bets bro let's
let's let's talk your favorite bets guys
let's suck your favorite bets get in the
chat talk to us let's grade some of
these
picks let's do it cool so we got bad
lands Vic
Steven Adams 10 plus points tonight I
believe it's plus 270 on FanDuel oh I I
took a gander at that I'm not gonna lie
I took a gander at Steven Adams plus 10
points and Memphis to win
thought about it did not pull trigger I
think he averages like six a game
um but it will be interesting it will be
interesting facing the Pelicans and
seeing if they are going to get Steven
Adams involved uh so I'll give it a The
Vibes just for Vibes I'll give it a B
minus
what about you Liv
I would say c plus only because of JJ's
return tonight I don't know how they're
gonna slide him in as a big man
offensively so
I'm gonna give it a c plus c plus
Okay C plus B minus right C plus B minus
so the grades are not high we're we're
like middle of the road as a class right
now uh read Phillips more Steven Adams
talk uh gotta peep Steven Adams double
double good matchup against Jonas
Valencia which I disagree I don't think
that's that great I don't think it's a
good matchup yeah I know at all but okay
Steven Adams double double we'll play
that game I feel like the grades might
be lower
what's the odds no no odds in there give
me Craig you know they know you don't
have to look them up Ryan because him
I'm not listening the odds is going to
affect the grade you know what I'm
saying totally the grade is being
affected for sure like a complete
assignment if you guys are putting those
comments in there has to be a complete
assignment and the complete assignment
is odds plus the bet so therefore I I
have to give this person the D I have to
give them a d because I don't know what
I don't know the odds they're still
passing
I mean yeah that's not an ass they can
graduate Maybe
yeah I would I think my reason the
reasoning that followed the bet is why
the grade is lower for me because I
disagree on it being a good matchup
against Valentine's I would actually say
the opposite valentina's playing his old
team I would trust him with my money a
lot more so because of the reasoning I'm
gonna bump it down to a c minus Okay C
minus these are grades that are not
going on the fridge just to reiterate
right yeah that's not happening right uh
El Martinez Marcus Morris over 20 and a
half points rebounds assists
well I think you like that right Liv
I sure do because I've got him scoring
over 13 and a half points so I'm gonna
have to give that that little uh that
little BET right there a good little a
I'm gonna give it an a
we got to keep the Vibes High
the first hey there it is and for The
Vibes and for Liv's better I'll give it
an a as well wow
that's huge for the chat uh all right
we'll do I'll do another one AJ the Don
Portland Trailblazers minus eight
against the San Antonio Spurs tonight
oh that's a good one I think the
Trailblazer's at home right Ryan
um yes they are
Spurs on the back to back I know this
when they played Warriors yesterday and
got blue out
they're gonna be tired
they're gonna be tired
that maybe yeah I like that
they might be on I'll give it a b they
might be onto something
it's gonna say b as well that's a that's
a that's a sneaky one that's a sneaky
good one they might be honest some
Trailblazers has been playing well too
they're same same uh record as your
Denver Nuggets live so
I like who I like that last pick I'll
give it a b all right we'll do we will
do one more and then we'll get out of
here uh jackham
Dame 30 plus points and Utah Jazz money
line and he dropped the odds Plus 250.
I love a guy that drops the odds yeah
booyah
there it is hey that's a a I'm rocking
with bro he getting the a I like Dane
jazz is like minus 200 or something like
that Ryan there's the parlay we were
talking about there's delay yeah there
is the leg literally right there
hey well let's end the show
let's end the show on that because the
Vibes are high The Vibes are high ride
the vibe into the sunset uh Hey if you
guys
don't know now you know Liv is a sharp
and she gave us six Best Bets that are
gonna hit my man Ryan man of the people
uh he's connected us to you guys all day
uh but it's time to get up out of here
guys it's time to get up out of here for
Greg Ivory live moves and producer Ryan
we
are out of here peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]